[Music]
thank you
cycling versus pedestrians there's been
a lot of interest in Britain this week
over the sad story of a woman cyclist
who died after an altercation with
Oriole gray a pedestrian oil gray has
been charged with manslaughter
but should Oriole gray really be going
to prison I'm joined by Mary dejeski who
is a spectator contributor as well as
another Mary Mary Wakefield who is our
commissioning editor
Mary dejevski I'll start with you
um your piece which was under the
headline cyclists have been given a
license to ride on the pavement uh went
down a storm on The Spectator website it
attracted lots of interest and judging
from the comments and so on this there
is a lot of concern out there obviously
especially among motorists and
pedestrians
that cyclists are being given the right
to ride on the pavement and that the
treatment of oriole gray is disgraceful
could you just outline for any viewers
that haven't been following it what's
happened to Oriel gray and the details
of that particular case
well what appears to have happened is
that she was walking along and it has to
be said she is a 46 year old woman
um who is partially sighted
um and has various other disabilities
and she was walking along the pavement
and she felt the disciplist
um was coming rather close to her
cycling on the pavement
and what is said is that and was given
in evidence is that she shouted swore at
the cyclist to get on the road and get
off the pavement and then she put her
hand out and there is also a question of
whether she actually hit her but the
consequence was catastrophic and tragic
which was that the cyclist
was pushed or fell off her bike into the
path of a vehicle that could not stop
and she was killed and that is the
source of the manslaughter charge that
the cyclist faced and she was convicted
of manslaughter she was sentenced to
three years in prison
and I think her lawyer says that she is
going to appeal but as yet there's no
news on that it's also I have to say
that I'm not clear whether she's been
given bail or whether she's been sent
straight to prison my impression is that
she's been sent to prison and I mean
I've seen the video and it's pretty
horrifying because of what happens but
uh it's not clear whether she pushed her
or not but if if Oriole gray did push
her and of course everybody feels sorry
for her in many ways because that was
obviously not her intention to uh to
kill this cyclist uh if she did push her
though that is uh a direct cause of the
death of the cyclist so there is a case
to be made
um that it is manslaughter if she did
push her is it is there not
yes I mean there there's the same case
that might be made
um against a cyclist or indeed a driver
um who knocks over somebody
um if he's
um speeding
um or um there was a case of a cyclist
who killed a pedestrian on a Crossing I
think
um and he was sentenced to 18 months in
prison only 18 months even though his
bike was defective and he cut through a
red light and he had no brakes
um it seems to me that there's a large
um there's a complete disproportion here
yes
um Mary number two uh
Mary says in her piece you know which of
us has not at some point wanted to shout
it out or wanted to shout out or even
push a cyclist because cyclists are
often quite obnoxious on the roads uh
they drive people crazy
um do you share that feeling I do I mean
I hate cyclists for the most part um I
think in this case
um the worry is the disproportionate
rage like you can hate a cyclist and
sort of swear at them and a lot of us
behave very badly but I do think there's
a problem with the disproportionate rage
people feel towards cyclists and I do
think it endangers them in some cases
because we're going fast you know I've
had people try and stick
um quite rightly in some ways you know a
walking stick through my front wheel
because they're enraged this is
particularly kind of going through
Kenston Gardens on a yeah I'm a
celebrating scientist but I mostly hate
a different sort of cyclist but that's
that's getting a little esoteric the
difference between cyclists it's the
commuting cyclists you know going down
going super fast to are unbelievably
rude who are the worst lot I think but
um so some of the things you can do to a
cyclist when you're feeling a bit cross
actually is incredibly dangerous for
them in this case you know a spasm of
Rage in involves the death of someone so
one of the lessons here is I think don't
be so disproportionately Furious that
you forget what your actions can can do
to someone going fast on a bike Mary
Mary dejeski I think that's right is it
not that um cyclists are scared because
uh a lot of the time they're driving
pretty fast through uh quite dangerous
roads and the reason they behave in the
way that they do and it's a way of
Behaving that annoys a lot of people is
because they're frightened a lot of the
time and when people are scared they
tend to act aggressively
well I think that's partly true but I
think if
if London and it has to be
um it happened in Huntington
might be seen sort of philosophically as
maybe closer to a cycling City such as
Cambridge
um than to London but if we look at
London
um then I would say look London has
spent
exorbitant amounts of money trying to
separate cyclists um from pedestrians
and cyclists from traffic there are
cycle Lanes all over London that have
backed up the traffic that have extended
people's Journeys if they're in cars or
buses
um incredibly it now takes me twice as
long to get from my flat to another part
of Central London than it did before the
introduction of cycle lens huge amounts
of money and if you look at these cycle
these cycling Lanes at many times of day
and there's hardly anybody in them all
the cyclists are in are in the the bus
lanes or the car lanes because they find
it quicker but the Carla hits and the
bus lanes they're now confined to 20
miles an hour and what happens is that
commuting cyclists are actually going
faster than 20 miles an hour but Mary
that's not our fault you know direct
your rage at siddique as a
cyclists
you're not using the site we didn't ask
for these cycle Lanes all of us this is
there's a lot of local government
um a war on the car going on and I blame
Boris frankly but you know that's
another thing
um and but it's not the fault of
individual cyclists so I feel like we
received the built up Rage of the
frustrated motorists who should be angry
at government both local and big
government for its war on on cars
and that's not our fault I didn't want a
ridiculous cycle laying down the
Melbourne road which frustrates me more
than anyone else you know where where
sort of channeled past bus stops where
it's very hard not to hit anyone because
the cycle Lane goes straight past the
you know place we it's I don't think
it's our fault
well I think it's your fault for not
using the lanes that you've been with
why should I have to use them if they're
there for riding on the pavement I don't
think there's any excuse for writing on
the paper but I completely agree with
that but but do you think perhaps the
reaction is disproportionate I mean
obviously in this case it was and the
whole thing's really unfortunate well I
think that I think that it's possible to
say that the reaction can be
disproportionate because everything has
now been piled on pedestrians it's not
just the cyclists we've got e-scooters
we've got e-bikes we've got skateboards
and everybody's really taking it as open
season for the pain but yeah that's the
only place where pedestrians can walk
but that affects us too you should I
mean that you should see the trouble
cyclists have with e-bikes on the bike
lane you know they're going at 30 miles
an hour where
I have every sympathy with that but I do
draw the line at cyclists on the papers
because I think that's that that is
really the that's where there is
competition and the only place where
pedestrians are can I'd have to have a
right to feel yeah I think that's
totally well maybe a little a little
finger wag rather than an actual shove
would be more proportionate
um a little finger finger wag and
a um a use of language shall we say
let's compromise on YouTube language
as I said it might be swearing is really
my register
I understand people who
I don't I don't want to interject
between two uh disagreeing Mary's but I
I do I do wonder if uh the headline of
your piece is is true uh you know have
uh cyclists do cyclists now have the
license to ride on the boat does does
this ruling mean that
well I think it's fair to extrapolate
from the ruling that it does recognize
um the right of a cyclist to to ride on
the pavement which wasn't there before
because my understanding is that the
default position before was that in most
cases it's illegal for cyclists to to
ride on the pavement even though that
isn't generally enforced
um but there seems to be a slight gray
area in this case because the Council of
of uh of all people seem to seem to be
confused as to whether this particular
part of the pavement was theoretically
something called a shared space where
cyclists could ride on the pavement and
where pedestrians were expected to share
nicely
um it didn't look when you see the
pictures and you see the CCTV it didn't
look to me very much like a shared space
but um that gray area I suspect is going
to loom rather large if there's an
appeal isn't that the problem then uh
Mary W that uh that this particular part
of road was not very clear what it was
this case is is an odd one isn't it
altogether because
um you know what was her name Oriole
gray is is reacts oddly she's not just
waving at her she actually is as I've
seen it looking at the footage
deliberately blocks the cyclist the
cyclist had she not been 77 herself and
a bit bewildered would have gone right
to the wall side but she didn't she
allowed herself to be uttered into the
road where there was a driver who I
don't think was paying attention so but
I also think that um the whole publicity
surrounding the case is less likely to
make me ride on Pavements I'm now more
scared I'm not incentivized I'm never
going on a pavement again it's a very
interesting and unusual case in the in
in in this it also in in the aspect that
the two cyclists were women of a certain
age
um and normally when you have these
these pavement conflicts you've got
young men in lycro dashing to get
somewhere or trying to deliver something
um and you've got
um say
um an elderly woman or somebody
partially decided trying to navigate all
the obstacles otherwise on the pavement
that's the usual conflict of interest on
Pavements this was slightly different
Mary and Mary I think we will have to
leave it there thank you both very much
for coming on to spectator TV
[Music]
thank you